well to talk about this issue a little
bit more we can go to central London and
speak to the playwright Bonnie Greer I'm
sure you were listening along to summer
for Rose Hudson welcome was saying there
some pretty powerful stuff from her
we've seen thousands of people taken to
the streets in the black lives matter
protests in recent days I mean some
people might be thinking why is it that
so many people are going out after
something that happened in America what
do you think it is that has given so
many people the urge to get out there
and demonstrate well let me say first of
all thank you for having me and also I
want to salute my friend Rose the first
black woman in the Church of England as
a bishop the bishop of Dover really this
is just very very typical of her of her
power and of her wise words and of her
activism in religion and in society so
really congratulations in Saluda she's a
beautiful role model I think one of the
things is because we saw this murder
we're all human beings and we saw this
and we knew this was wrong and I think
what it did was release in everybody
everybody a goodwill the feeling that
this is enough I grew up in Chicago I
was born and raised the United States
and this is not an unusual thing to
happen to particularly a black man but
now in this age we can see it when I was
in the streets in 68 we could we knew
things but we couldn't see them but now
we can and that's what's important one
thing I want to gently disagree with
with with rose I think that what why
revolutions fail and particularly why my
generation couldn't extend what we did
is because we forgot that taking down a
statue is a political act but we have to
have a cultural act after that because
we human beings make culture and I
understand that the Colston statue is in
a museum now and they are discovering
not only what the statute was made of
they're discovering the workers
made the Statue they're looking at the
the artifacts that have made on the
statue at the moment of taking it down
and these are teaching tools that's why
I'm in the studio of my friend the
artist londre oleg okay here because it
is culture at the end of the day which
it stands for evolution and we have to
have a cultural act and I'm associate
with museums too and museums now must
have a cultural act that act involves
not only displaying and taking in black
life matter artifacts because now these
are cultural icons as well so that
future generations can know that it
happened because believe it or not there
will be a time when some young person
will be walking down the street in
Bristol and you know instead of seeing
the beautiful statue of darkness how
which will be there you'll say well
actually that used to be a statue of a
slaver then let's say mommy that's wrong
I don't believe it so you take them
somewhere you teach them you show them
you have to extend Revolution political
acts with acts of culture it is
extremely important in museums and the
first line of that have to step up to
the plate and do acts of culture and I
think many of them are ready to do it
it's interesting because it does feel
like the statues have been a flashpoint
whether the statues that we saw in
Bristol for example or the desecration
of the Churchill statue in Westminster
are you worried that this is becoming a
distraction that some people particular
when it comes to the Churchill's chap
statue feel very strongly against this
goes back to my point statues are
cultural icons they are acts of culture
they're not only political acts their
acts of culture and in going to a statue
and I don't condone defacing or taking
down statues it's not what I would do
but I understand why people do what they
do because you see a statue we saw a
murder you see a statue where human
beings of senses that's what we are and
so we have to actually extend that pull
if
act and make it a cultural act it's not
enough to be in the street it's not
enough we were in the street what is
next has to happen is that we have to
make culture we have to extend culture
we have to talk culture because that's
what lives
that's what guarantees that's when
shrines what we do and I love these
activists majority of them because they
are actually first of all they're
leaderless which i think is the most
powerful statement they can be we don't
need any leaders for this and also at
the same time they are making culture as
they move let's preserve it because
there will be people behind us let's
make it let's talk about it let's show
it so that we can talk not only to our
own time but to the time after this
because we don't those statues will be
erected again because people will forget
thank you very much for being on the
program
Bonnie gray a very interesting take from
you and what we've seen in recent weeks
thank you thank you